the traditional metrics will reflect
purpose over time so having purpose with
being purpose led is not the absence of
metrics but it's the it's prioritizing
the purpose before the metrics and
purpose led organizations over time will
demonstrate better metrics so the
companies that are Purpose Driven tend
to be more profitable have better a
tenure of their employees more loyalty
over time more loyalty from their
customers and and and the traditional
metrics tend to reflect that the it's
it's in a short term that the metrics
are not very useful right it's because
sometimes we make we make purposeful
sacrifices to do the right thing if
you're a Purpose Driven or an infinite
minded so I had a meeting I had a
meeting at the Pentagon once and you
know when you have a meeting and
somebody you wait in the foyer and then
someone comes to get you and then you
walk to the meeting right you walk to
the hall and you have this hallway talk
it's it's to fit because it's too
uncomfortable to talk about nothing and
it's too premature to start the meeting
so we just like say how's the weather
you know did you have trouble finding it
you know did you have trouble getting
here and we sort of have this nonesense
hallway talk and then we walk in the
conference room it ends immediately and
we start the meeting
right so I was at the Pentagon and this
big general came to get me from the
foyer and we're walking down the hall to
his office for the meeting and so we're
making hallway talk and he says hey
Simon
I had everyone in my in my office read
your book and I said my publisher thanks
you
and he said tell them not to bother
I had them read my copy total book sales
1 total impact huge compared going to an
event where they give out 500 free
copies of my book total book sales 500
but people use them as coasters and
doorstops total impact 0 and so in the
short term it looks better being at the
event from 500 than selling one but if I
wait over the course of time that will
yield better book sales because those
people will tell their friends to read
it and their friends will go buy a book
will tell different so the point is is
if I wait
overtime book sales absolutely help me
recognize is the movement growing but
not in any particular month I don't care
about and I don't care about what the
end like people say how many books do
you wanna sell per year how many
speeches do you want to do per year I
don't care it makes no difference to me
whether it's this year next year what I
want is momentum the way I measure
success with the metrics is the is is is
the momentum going like this and and and
the exact dates and the exact numbers
it's like I want to lose a certain
amount of weight by a certain date but
what happens if you don't lose the
weight by that date well you're still
way healthier than you were even though
you missed the goal so the goals are
good because they help drive us and
motivate us but if you hit it or make it
it doesn't matter in the infinite game
it's a guidance not an absolute finite
views metrics is absolute infinite views
metrics as a measure of speed and
distance they're guides
we're going fast or we're going slow so
yes metrics are hugely important
you can't run a marathon without metrics
you need to know how fast and how far
right you need metrics but but the
question is is is how we view them so
traditional metrics are perfectly fine
[Music]
[Music]